Je vous en prie, installez vous.
Merci.
Alors, vous venez pour
la visite médicale c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ça.
– Bien.
Je peux en prendre un ?
Ils sont là pour ça.
Faites surtout pas ça !
Pardon ?!
Non allez-y, ils sont là pour ça.
Faites pas ça c'est un piège !
Je vous taquine, allez-y.
Bien, on va pouvoir commencer !
– Vous fumez !
– Non...
Très bien! On va passer au test de vue.
Dites-moi qu'est-ce que vous voyez là.
Ben un Z.
Non, c'est un N. Un peu penché.
Bien, maintenant dîtes-moi
ce que vous voyez ici.
Je dirais un B.
Non, c'est un faucon pélerin.
On le voit à ses deux ailes
caractéristiques et à son bec crochu
qui en font un animal rapide et élégant.
Avec des yeux équipés pour chasser,
Il voit ses proies à plusieurs
centaines de mètres.
Et vous ?
Vous pouvez voir à
plusieurs centaines de mètres ?
Ben, non...
Dommage.
Allez, on va s’asseoir s’il vous plait.
Allongez vous.
Non, au temps pour moi, restez assis.
Non, couché.
-Hm, assis.
Ah! Perdu!
Ca suffit maintenant…
Réflexe.
Alors dîtes-moi, ça vous fait mal
si j'appuie là ?
Ben non...
– Pourquoi ?
Parce que c’est votre joue.
Et là ?
-Ben c’est toujours pa…
Haaaa!
Vous êtes complètement malade!
Réflexe.
Test d'effort !
Ça va ? Vous allez bien ?
Je sais pas...
Vous inquiétez pas, j’ai exactement ce qu’il vous faut,
je vois très bien ce que vous avez,
Je vais vous prescrire...
un générique.